elon musk and jeff bezos have been
fighting for the title of the richest
man in the world for quite some time to
be honest they've been fighting for more
than just this title there's also the
title of first unreasonably rich human
to conquer space which according to us
elon musk is currently winning and
lastly the title of most petty
billionaire which to be fair both have a
fair chance at landing let's take a look
at the rivalry between these two super
billionaires and see how they've tried
to one-up each other through the years
without further ado it's time to dive
right in 1. the space race no this is
not the u.s vs soviet union space race
this is the latest and not by a long
shot greatest race to the moon the
current space race is between elon musk
with his company spacex and jeff bezos
with his company blue origin both the
companies have the same goal to conquer
space what conquering space means to
each of them isn't the same thing though
elon musk wants to colonize mars as
early as 2026 while jeff bezos has a
more interstellar themed approach he
wants to make wait for it giant
cylindrical space cities that can
function as exoplanets for humanity's
future growth both contestants have
different but equally wild ideas and
while they are both fueled by the same
thing wanting to save humanity and to
flex his win over the other they both
disagree on several important factors as
for where both of them stand it's a
mixed debate so we'll just give you the
facts and leave it up to you to decide
elon musk was the first one to suggest
reusable rockets that can re-land and
then be reused his company spacex used
that idea as its main selling point and
have now perfected the entire operation
they were the first in the world to do
it and so far have the highest success
rate blue origins recently saw success
with their own reusable rocket program
and have started making it better bit by
bit spacex has the clear advantage of
additional experience while blue origins
is banking on something far more magical
beginners luck secondly elon musk has
also criticized jeff bezos's plan to set
up a system of satellites to provide
super fast internet his complaint bezos
is a copycat elon musk claims that bezos
is trying to copy the idea of his
company starlink starlink if you don't
know is elon musk's latest claim to fame
starlink has a system of satellites
spread across the earth and provides
high-speed internet in previously
unreachable places the idea is great the
execution is also pretty decent given
that this is the first time in history
that this is happening there are some
minor complaints but given how elon musk
has overcome pretty much every challenge
thrown at him we're confident he can
work his way around a few simple slow
connection issues 2. the richest man on
earth jeff bezos with his rather
impressive list of companies has been
dominating the list of richest people on
earth for quite some time now but
recently elon musk dethroned him this
happened back in september 2021 and up
till now the two have changed places
more than a few times elon musk
currently sits at the top with a net
worth of
229.6 billion dollars while jeff bezos
is at second place with
194.1 billion dollars elon is quite
proud of this achievement and friendly
banter between the two is quite common
on the subject just this month on the
11th of october elon musk tweeted a
number two medal under jeff bezos's
tweet about how far amazon has come
imagine the richest and arguably the
most successful people on the planet
trying to shade each other every chance
they get it was hilarious and to make
things even more interesting elon musk
managed to ratio bezos under bezos's own
tweet if you're not up to date on the
latest twitter lingo ratio means to get
more likes on your tweet replying to
someone than the actual tweet you're
replying to think of it as a comedic
standout and you getting more clapping
on your comeback this isn't all elon
musk had to say about the situation in
fact when he first crossed jeff bezos
forbes reached out for a comment and
elon musk replied i'm sending a giant
statue of the digit 2 to jeffrey b along
with a silver medal talk about burns
sheesh 3. self-driving cars elon musk is
known for spacex starlink and tesla jeff
bezos took on spacex and starlink so
it's only natural that he would come
after tesla too tesla is one of the most
successful of elon musk's brain children
the company is the leading producer of
electric cars and is an industry leader
in the game in fact elon musk is
credited to be the person that set up
the market for electric cars back when
tesla was first launched no one cared
nor wanted to care about an electric car
they were seen as slow expensive and
frankly just not worth it elon musk
single-handedly changed the perspective
of the entire car market and now his
electric cars teslas are the hottest
wheels on the road to compete with tesla
jeff bezos bought the self-driving car
company zuke's elon musk claims that
self-driving vehicles are the future and
they're going to completely take over
the market as the technology gets
cheaper and more widely available
whether self-driving cars are safe or
not is a whole debate which is frankly
very boring so instead of focusing on
that we're going to just agree on the
fact that self-driving cars are insanely
cool after all who doesn't want a car
that can drive itself while you binge
watch a netflix show in the background
zooks is a bit different from tesla
since tesla lets you get your own
autonomous vehicle whereas zooks is a
ride-hailing company imagine uber but
the car drives itself according to elon
jeff bezos used the infamous i'll copy
your homework but change it up a bit so
no one knows tactic what do you think is
jeff bezos really a copycat or are all
his ideas just coincidentally similar to
musks let me know in the comments 4. the
pettiest billionaire when it comes to
being petty both elon musk and jeff
bezos have got quite a lot of experience
under the hood the approaches are
different however elon musk uses tweets
and sarcasm to clap back while jeff
bezos tries being the gentleman and
handling things a bit more
professionally by launching lawsuit
after lawsuit spacex landed a 2.9
billion dollar contract with nasa to
which blue origin jeff bezos's company
responded by filing a lawsuit elon musk
clapped back and said jeff bezos has
retired from the helm of amazon to
pursue a full-time job filing lawsuits
against spacex sick roast i know the
lawsuit tried to get nasa to reconsider
their offer and choose blue origin
instead elon musk had something to say
about this too and tweeted a photo of
blue origin's model and in all honesty
we can see why nasa decided not to go
with them after the actual lawsuit was
filed elon musk decided to take another
jab and tweeted if lobbying and lawyers
could get you to orbit jeff bezos would
be on pluto right now if you're under
the impression that the rivalry started
recently you're dead wrong bezos has
been filing lawsuits since before his
company was even launching rockets and
musk has been replying to them with some
sweet comebacks in 2013 facex tried to
get exclusive access to a nasa launch
pad and were stopped by a protest by
several of his competitors including
jeff bezos's blue origin musk called the
move a phony blocking tactic and decided
to make fun of blue origin once again
blue origin has not yet succeeded in
creating a reliable sub-orbital
spacecraft despite spending over 10
years in development musk told space
news at the time if they do somehow show
up in the next five years with a vehicle
qualified to nasa human rating standards
that can dock with the space station
which is what pad 39a is meant to do we
will gladly accommodate their needs
frankly i think we are more likely to
discover unicorns dancing in the flame
duct he added elon musk has also called
out jeff bezos for being a copycat
multiple times and even tweeted that
jeff bezos is a copycat with the word
copy followed by a cat emoji this tweet
was in response to the news of amazon
acquiring zukes in an interview elon
musk was asked how he felt about his
competition with jeff bezos his reply
jeff bezos also had something to say
about elon musk's plan to go to mars in
a 2019 talk he said my friends who want
to move to mars i say do me a favor go
live on the top of mount everest for a
year first and see if you like it
because it's a garden paradise compared
to mars both of them disagree on quite a
lot of points but you have to agree that
this rivalry has pushed advances in
space technology high-speed internet
service and even the automobile industry
to new levels and at the end of the day
both of them engage in friendly banter
they're rivals not enemies that was it
for this video we hope you enjoyed it
let us know your thoughts in the
comments and i'll see you next time